I'm gonna put some bubbles in there as
well wow yeah it might look like just a
bit of fun but play sessions in the
children's Ward at Kingston Hospital are
about so much more for three-year-old
siligan it's a welcome distraction after
being admitted with breathing problems
I was stuck in I don't know how to
entertain him he's more emotional and
like very frustrated but as soon as like
we came here I took a look at him
quickly go to the bathroom and then she
just he just started playing with things
that he enjoys and then now he's really
calm
and sometimes obviously by having him
calm that's going to help him as well
because when he's crying that makes his
breathing worse and that's just going to
prolong it
but with NHS budgets under so much
pressure paying for play Specialists has
become low priority for some hospitals
since the pandemic with the need to
control infection delaying many
playrooms reopening
it's something the health play charity
Starlight says has to change we want
there to be mandatory Health Place
services in every Healthcare setting
where there are children because it's so
important to them so we're working with
NHS England to look into questions of
Standards guidance and most importantly
for all Health authorities to make the
funding available to provide the
services that children need
the charity wants national standards to
be developed and adopted across the
board
five out of every six of the health care
settings applying for support from the
charity Starlight said they didn't have
access to a play budget at all and of
those that said they did 70 had less
than 500 pounds to spend a year
Julie Morris sees the Power of play
every day in her role at the hospital
it can be preparing children for
procedures it can be
um
getting children used to having I don't
know blood tests observations and then
through their whole Hospital journey and
so they were able to cope with things
when they get home if they have to come
back in again they're able to sort of
cope with them and know that then it was
scary because we've explained it and
gone through it with them
after a night in hospital siligan is
about to head home the stress of the
experience eased not only for him but
his mother too
Emma virtually Sky News Kingston upon
Thames